hi
you're in the right place you did click
on a three scary games video
the best three scary games videos around
no one else does him like i do them
whatever my name may be who cares really
all that matters
is that you're here
with me
for the duration of this video
and we're going to have so
much fun
what did you expect to jump scare
no
silly [ __ ] we're gonna get right into
it we're starting off with a game called
this game is real i'm not sure what they
mean by that but this game seems to be
some kind of real i am real this game is
real
what kind of reel are we talking about
here oh
oh strange
okay
hello
i'm glad i stand at sitting height all
right
very real battery do i have a very real
flashlight waiting for me very real old
cell phone
very real
oh that
okay creativity time and love
and then whoa
whatever that is
and a spoon
or a
bone
hello
odd
i seem to collect some very strange
things
oh that's oh that's never
a good sign
oh
that's not a good sign either what did
that painting ever do to you
oh
my other computer room interesting
oh no it's another bedroom what is this
a streamer house
why are all the faces all blopped out
now why is it so really quiet in here
why are all the windows borah bricked up
[Music]
grandma
oh
oh grandma no
oh no no no no
i'm sorry what was that
who's doing that and why is this the
thing that it is great
okay good
excellent
what am i doing and why am i doing it
and whoa
no that was open
oh was that closed
what happened what just happened what
was that
what was that
okay okay okay
is anything different
seems to have
about the same
there's something on the ground there a
basket good
okay
whoo
he is coming better ride
um well i would love to how how do i
hide underneath here no i can't oh god
he's coming who he him him that guy who
is he
who's coming is he really a thing
also i just noticed the battery symbol
peeping up down the bottom left i didn't
notice that before almost seems like the
oh
almost seems like the screens of the
wrong
resolution i'm assuming
that that note was a lie
a dirty rotten stinky lie and there's no
one coming after me
because that would be ridiculous
that would be completely ridiculous that
would be absurd look if someone probably
just ate some ribs in my closet and
that's why there was a spine and some
bones left over that's the only reason
you lied to me
it's not real you're not real
and most importantly i'm not real and
this game definitely is not real right
who's here hm
who's here who's coming huh
if you're coming right now let me see it
let me see it show me
huh he
he who is coming
you better get out of here you better
come out here
come where i am okay
good grin i guess no one's coming
[Music]
i didn't expect that to open are you
coming in here
is he gonna come get me in here
oh i have a flashlight
i didn't know i had a flashlight
i didn't exactly need one but now i know
i have one
oh that's not good
oh
you are safe here stay with whoo
hey hey hey oh never mind i didn't get a
choice about this
oh is this my [ __ ] bucket
oh okay
okay it's very lovely here yes all right
cool
just be here
maybe i can leave maybe i'll leave
nope can't leave
oh [ __ ]
ominous piano stings are never a good
sign
i'm apparently a baby
oh
what's happening what's happening
did i do that
oh no oh no
oh no
okay
yay good freedom freedom
all right
oh that is interesting i got a
checkpoint now why
would someone need me
to have a checkpoint it's not like i'm
in any danger right
what did i grab
did i grab a battery
i don't trust that [ __ ]
oh don't trust that [ __ ] either
oh definitely don't trust the bugs
crawling in my ears
oh
no definitely don't trust the things
going in reverse
you coming in here who's there
what do we got going on
huh
what do we got going on whoa
uh wait what oh that's problem um okay
well it's a good thing tv screens are
one way and oh god it's everywhere
okay good great yeah that's good that's
great oh god here too yeah great
great
great i guess i know where all the eyes
went that was not bugs before but okay
what what oh good what what why oh the
burning bush okay um don't know what
that was all about don't even know what
i saw at the end of the hallway it was
gone so fast uh but i'm sure it was fine
and i'm sure it was fun
okay oh
you are next i don't know who's first
and i don't even know what happened to
them just because of blood everywhere
doesn't mean they're dead maybe they had
fun
well
oh
come find me i have something to show
you oh
i got a key
i didn't see that before oh i hate it
i hate it my flashlight does dick
my flashlight does nothing
oh my flashlight does nothing
oh it does so much nothing
oh no
none of these doors are gonna work are
they
oh no they're not
oh no they're not
i know a fruitless task when i see one
yeah down good yeah it's good it feels
safe it always feels safe to go down
into this weird dungeon that attaches to
my apartment for whatever reason
also i don't think i had a front door on
my apartment unless this is the front
door in which case again i have more
questions i should have thought more
oh
oh
that was not
cool oh my god
okay yeah cool nice white mask that that
should not have gotten me like that i
just was not prepared
for whatever the hell this tube of meat
is
i
what's in here i shouldn't look in here
something's gonna jump out at me in
there probably not probably maybe
apparently nothing did
oh man that one
that one got me
good uh
okay
that's normal
what happened
oh
apparently i reloaded double in my
flashlight oh yeah um
uh
all right oh what's in here oh i see you
i see you in there i see you
i see you
i see you in there okay i'm getting real
scp-087
vibes
getting real scp-087 vibes here
the infinite stairwell of doom i am
feeling that oh yeah good
also i never questioned the idea that
those were in my bathroom
goopy but i suppose that's not the
weirdest thing has happened why did you
do this i thought we were safe with you
you are a monster
me
am i the monster or am
i'm the monster okay
you are not a monster they don't
understand i do
who doesn't understand what and who are
you and who are they more specifically
who are any of us really
don't look behind you oh too late
i think you scared me with that that's
my joke but seriously
don't look behind you
just wait
it'll be gone soon but you can't
look
behind you
turn around
[Music]
whatever you do
don't turn around
okay it's gone
maybe
okay so that opened but what's down here
what's over here i'm a curious george
i'm very curious i'm a curious george
i'm curious oh nothing
who's there
perfect opportunity for a spook and you
didn't take it uh
shame
uh never mind i take it back i'm sorry
what was i saying
hey
hey
how you doing whoa big guy
oh are you real wait no hang on oh
you're actually a thing in is this a
maze oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no it's a maze isn't it or it's a
square at the worst
oh i should have been following it
okay
i don't know
i don't know
hello
sure love the big clog stompers in here
love that they're all in here with me oh
weird
that's fine
very unis honest
i don't know if i'm just like missing
these guys by random happenstance or i
am incredibly skilled
i'd be willing to bet that i'm
incredibly skilled oh hi you in timeout
ah sorry i can't help you
okay
okay oh hi oh hi nice cod piece all
right
checkpoints ahoy
all right strange dungeon uh the mix of
technology here is really throwing me
off
getting amnesia vibes getting like
you know my computer room vibes oh hello
baby oh so i see you're taken oh hi i
see you
okay
very strange
what you doing up here oh you're smiling
oh you're so cute when you smile
you so [ __ ] precious when you smile
murderer
people of glass houses shouldn't cast
stones
oh no murder
oh boy never good when a skeleton floats
up in a bathtub full of blood i've had
that happen a few times in my life and
it
never ends well as plain old not good
is what they say about that anywho
what do i do about that
do i hop in there with you
it's hard to feel bad about something i
don't know what i did
you see what i mean
hard to feel
any sort of moral quandary when i'm
rather uncertain of the
circumstances by which i have been
accused
oh
haven't gone this way
oh it keeps going
oh it keeps going
all right more bones always good
oh
well you don't look so good
yeah you'll be all right
okay so there's got to be some kind of a
conclusion here
some kind of conclusion oh
uh
should i put myself in this oh what the
hell oh what the frick
what am i looking at whoa
whoa weird
oh very weird it's like a screen
oh [ __ ] there goes my batteries
oh what the hell
okay so there's got to be a way to get
through this that's to do with something
about this because why would they go
through the trouble of making this
effect
looking at that through what looks like
this camera for some reason
very weird
am always behind you
oh
not in the game in real life hey
hey now
that's my trick i'm not alone we are all
keeping it close eye at you let us take
control and your suffering will end
go look inside your
head
go look inside your head
maybe now i gotta stick my head in the
stockade
is that what i gotta do
this is what i get
i'm looking inside my head
i'm looking oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh it opened
oh
hey bud
i'm looking inside my head
i'm ready ah
i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready
[Music]
all right oh oh hey
hey
hey what's up
what's up big guy
oh
you made the right choice go back to
sleep now
well i don't know what i did you fall
asleep uh
uh
i'm okay
getting real sleepy real fast i'm a
quick sleeper i i just go right out when
i conk i conk
oh
a bit confusing like not bad no don't
get me wrong this game was good i i
enjoyed it it definitely had the
atmosphere especially in the early
stages of it but at the same time
i'm kind of confused
i don't really understand what the moral
quandary was it accused me of being a
murderer and i kept saying like this
game is real and uh that's spooky but i
i i'm left with like a a sense of
dissatisfaction because i just didn't
understand what the stakes were but the
game was good it it had some spookiness
to it it it really did so anyway link in
the description but we gotta move on
this game is made by the same person
that made discover my body
sister it's called lips like
vellum
which is weird please wake up
please listen you've got to get out of
the house father can't be trusted i
didn't just disappear we were both born
to be taken by god you must leave
or suffer the same fate as me
search the room
there is a way out
find
bob and be brave tonight for your own
sake okay
who's bob why is your hair so drippy uh
what happened to you where am i
oh god you have been contacted by your
sister clara in your sleep she has given
you an urgent message to leave the house
it would be wise to search the room for
anything she might have left behind oh
oh my
all right
interesting can't seem to click on
anything am i clicking correctly
can't seem to do
anything oh
you're in your bedroom your bed sits in
the corner by your dresser there is a
crisp draft coming in through the open
window
okay so that's what dee does
oh what
what
your window it's quite cold standing in
front of it the wind blows in gently
weird
oh very weird
oh very weird
you are by your closet it has been
locked and changed up ever since clara
disappeared you can't remember being in
it in your short life
my short life
the heavy combination lock put on the
door after clara disappeared your father
is the only one with a combination to
your knowledge weird oh this is weird
everything about it is just unsettling
it's kind of the same as like the other
game it's just the style is unsettling
this door leads out to the hallway on
your left is a shelf on your right is a
mirror all right
you got geode
all right
i got you
got crumpled note
do i have an inventory i do read
lisa i know you understand that you are
not to move from your room tonight but i
went ahead and locked the door anyway i
will come collect you when the time is
right don't try anything i will know
weird blunt rock with crystals
noah scrawled writing
start with the number three then the
numbers are up by the first till the
third the last number is the third down
by the second i'm sorry
uh i don't like that your mirror quite
dusty you look like a ghost in the
reflection yeah
probably something to that isn't there
oh
god i hate that
why are these colored
holidays and their origins the modern
holiday of halloween finds its roots in
the celtic semaine festival this day
marked the division of the year from the
lighter half of the darker half the
ancient celts observed this day with
caution understanding that the boundary
between this world and the other world
became
thinner
right all right
on fairy doors a fairy door is a
miniature door usually set into the base
of a tree or cliff behind which may be
small cavities for the leaving of gifts
offering or notes the construction of a
fairy door ought to be done for best
results with all natural materials or
materials consecrated on an auspicious
day
right on crabs about one quarter of the
done dungeness crab's weight is meat the
flesh has what is considered to be a
delicate flavor and slightly sweet taste
dungeness crabs can typically be
purchased either live or cooked live
crabs are cooked simply by dropping them
into boiling salt water waiting for the
boil to return and then allowing for it
to continue for 15 minutes after which
time the crabs are removed and placed
into cold water to cool and then cleaned
i now know more than grabs that i ever
have in my life start with the number
three okay start with the number three
the numbers are up by the first till the
third
the last number is third down
by the second if i'm reading this right
which i doubt i am they mean
start with three then it's up by the f
by the first which would mean three six
nine
until the 3rd
then it's down by the second
the last number is the third
down by the second
so the third which would be 9
down by six would be three again
is that what it is
oh my god
i got it
holy hell in hell i actually solved a
puzzle
so i'm in
you are inside your closet heavy boxes
line the wall there's a scrape on the
wall
that looks like a vagina as you slide
the box a dark wet hole is revealed a
strange coppery smell drifts from it
i don't trust
that
that is bizarre you get the feeling it
would be unwise to enter without being
properly equipped yeah i don't have my
body condom on
very important what if i use either the
rock here you know what i mean
i was thinking maybe to
tear it off there but if i use it on the
mirror
you know what i mean get a few years of
bad luck but i oh [ __ ]
well there's no reflection anymore buddy
boo
got glass shard well
looks like someone's well equipped
oh i don't like it the whole close is
quickly behind you i don't feel like
that's normal for holes
dude you're in a dark wet tunnel a dank
smell hangs in the air
all right
oh
hi how are you doing
what's up you look like one of the
things from either princess mononoke or
uh my neighbor tutorial who are you
who are you please i knew clara
well your blood smells the same or
similar
very similar what do you want
how do i find bob you don't know you
really did just wander in here
well
just follow the red mushrooms that's it
well you seem friendly i hope you don't
die bye bye thanks buddy boo
good luck
all right
you can barely see your hands in front
of you
well
the red mushrooms i have no reason to
doubt
[Music]
there is no light here at all the
darkness seems to fold everything into
it you cannot even be sure of the
direction you came in
you can only hear oh that was actually
something you cannot see anything at all
very dark and very quiet you can only
hear the sound of your heart beating and
the blood rushing in your head
okay
oh
what did i do something stirs in the
darkness
oh i hate that
what is that bob oh that's not good oh
that's not good oh that's definitely not
bob blood
good blood
yours was so sweet so tasty blood blood
blood a young girl's blood
i love the young blood i love the
carpeting the texture sometimes i eat up
the little children sometimes i cannot
help myself
the bones are soft and the skin is sweet
but why did you give me your blood would
you like to be friends what can i do for
you
my friend
are you bob
i have many names that is my little
child name yes bob
but why did you give me your blood
would you like to be friends
let's see why do you wear that mask
what mask but why did you give me your
blood i need help getting out of my room
out of your room
i know someone who can do that i know a
friend who can do that he might need
something from you someday though
something more than
blood oh blood
sweet blood
please calm for me
[Music]
it's already done he's waiting outside
your window
now leave before i eat you up
i have no idea what that was all right
good goodbye okay no more hole
that's normal
that's definitely normal that's normal
this is all normal
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
your window it is quite cold standing
the wind blows gently
[Laughter]
hello sweetheart
who are you i'm an
angel
from
heaven
i made something just for you please
don't mind if it's a little wet
why is it wet just remember
this will cost you but you knew that
got bone key
[Music]
great thank you
thank you oh god already okay
thanks for the loan key i guess i'll use
it
unlocked
[Music]
not what i was expecting
at the end of my haul
well
that's the end of the demo
hope you enjoy playing
you can exit the game by either hitting
the escape key or clicking the x on the
window
right
is that really it just gonna end like
that i got a glass shard maybe i can
maybe i can shank them
ah well
dad uh i'm guessing that's who you are
uh
good talking to you
i guess that's it okay all right well we
got lips like vellum and and let me tell
you let me tell you
that's some vellum lips so uh surreal
weird but god damn if it wasn't
interesting there's something about this
unsettling style that i love i love it a
lot it's limited in a lot of ways but
god i love it it's just like the ms-dos
style
super cool
super well done all right moving on to
the next one
oh boy micro horror arcade back at it
again dpt
this is a game about pt and dr pepper
dpt makes sense that's all you need to
know
and it's made by micro horror arc oh my
god oh my god
yes
[Music]
i haven't had one of those since
1979
say little billy
could you go grab your grape grandpappy
some dr pepper out of them now that
would really put a big old smell on your
grandpappy's face
come on now
i'm thirsty you said not since 1972 and
yet you are literally sitting in a
squaller of dr pepper there's dr pepper
strewn about the entirety of the
backyard grandpa i think that you are
full of [ __ ] and you are just sending me
out on a wild goose chase the likes of
which will end in my own death all right
fine whatever man you know what grampy
i love you i really love you so i'm
gonna go
no i'm not because i have no idea where
am i going what am i doing
ramps what am i
how do i do i didn't look at the
controls too deeply so i don't 100 no i
gotta click on it
right
oh
very resident evil
very
interesting ah
dr pepper
good for life
okay
great
i love this
i love it a lot
woohoo a lift for life
yay
all right good uh is this a store
the hell is happening here
what is any of this supposed to be
i can crawl through
[Applause]
right
what the frick is happening
i don't understand any of this
oh
no it's p t
i get it oh
i see
so i'm going to be stuck in a loop
[Music]
[Music]
you son of a [ __ ] you're trying to kill
me i knew it grampy bambi oh grampy baby
i knew it
i knew you were trying to kill me i knew
it all along grampy maps i knew you were
trying to kill me i can't see a goddamn
thing sure wish i had a flashlight but i
do not all i have is the light of the
fridge to go by okay so what am i
supposed to do
oh
i was supposed to close the fridge
[Music]
oh
okay that makes sense
all right um
sure
yeah
uh-huh
okay
good great great great even good great
all right round three baby
run it again play the theme song let's
get this thing bopping in here
if i love me it's my grandpa and some dr
pepper that's what i love in that order
absolutely
[Applause]
absolutely oh god you
just blow out my eardrums why don't you
just just just just destroy him just
shred him just shred him you know you
know you're on thin ice now you're on
thin ice you're on thin ice you're on
thin ice you're on thin ice huh you're
on thin ice you're on thin ice you
better watch yourself dr pepper can't
survive it's thin ice temperatures such
as the legs that pretend that made sense
turn down the volume so i saved my
goddamn eardrums
what's going on over there
what's going on what's going on over
there
oh
wow
what am i looking at
what am i seeing
and why am i going near it okay
all good baby i'm assuming i'm not going
back yeah all right all good baby all
good all good baby everything is good
from here good great great
still on thin ice you're still thin ice
micro horror arcade
you're on thin ice okay
i'm beginning to think that my grandpa
is a curse eldritch demon from another
dimension and i'm just gonna die
or worse yet i'm not gonna die i'm gonna
be perpetually looping through an
endless nightmare
really
really
you're not even gonna let me go through
you're gonna make me go back every time
huh
i see how it is
huh okay i see
i see
oh
you dick you did make me just go back
all the way over here
like a [ __ ] expecting that
something's gotta pop out of me in any
minute
no no no no
no no no no no
yeah okay
yeah okay yeah okay
grandpa i'm beginning to think that this
trip ain't worth it i'm beginning to
think that my sanity and my my mental
stability is starting to become
compromised
also our house laughs real weird i keep
getting lost
he's running a loopy loop
oh straight through
weird i thought there was going to be
something all right you're subverting my
expectations but for what purpose
what's this leading up to
and how is it going to destroy my life
that's a different sound
okay
[Music]
oh no
oh no what
what's happening
[Applause]
oh
okay
i'm not even gonna look behind me
because i don't want to know i don't
know what kind of slurpee demon was
cracking open a cold one behind my ears
because frankly no one needs to know
that that's totally fine just leave that
oh my god who punched holes into
literally everything
or is it the delicious carbonation
that's building up inside of him
yum yum yum yay
okay good
guess can't have anyone known the secret
23 flavors
21 20 how many flavors 18
oh everything's fine
you run that by me again
what are you doing over there hmm
yum oh
what
what the hell
what the hell oh now i get a flashlight
oh now now i get a flashlight oh now now
great
good i don't know what i saw the weird
honeycomb tryptophobia [ __ ] i saw in
the freezer
but
certainly couldn't have been the 23
delicious flavors of dr pepper
in this hellscape of horrors
oh
it's even more red
all right
all right
all right
all right
oh this is some good stuff
yes
yeah this is what i call the good stuff
this is
top quality
when i think of dr pepper i think it
whoa
getting a little grumbly here grandpa
please i'm hurrying as best i can to get
you your sweet delicious dr pepper
gotta have some patience with me
oh oh oh oh that's oh
oh
oh hey hey listen
oh i thought i was in a hurry
okay all right
oh hi
all right so
did i do something wrong
you're displeased with my waist
first of all rude and second of all
my images ought to be fixed excuse you
survive and you shall see the way hey
listen i was just jumping in oh sh
i'm sorry i'm not understanding what
you're saying you need to enunciate
can i find it
something about a power that can end up
to the wall but i frankly i don't know
because why would i know
you know what i mean
you feel me you're picking up what i'm
putting down i think yeah
there we go apparently i found it
no idea what i found
what was that did i just see
what did i just see clip through the
goddamn fridge
what did i just see
oh what
okay strawberry man
what what's the problem what's the
problem my dude i don't get it i don't
get it is this just a tryptophobia-based
game is that what this is all about
is that what we're dealing with here
i
am unclear
i think i know what i need to do
oh [ __ ] god damn it i know i need to
hide
that's what it wants me to do in this
closet probably it didn't trigger until
i opened this
so it must want me to go yeah
definitely
yeah
that's why this exists
oh lights came back on is that good did
i do it did i get it did i win
i think i might have won i think i might
have won
nope apparently i didn't win what do i
need to do do i need to go back to the
beginning
oh [ __ ] off
oh really
really
i
all right now you know actually i'm good
i'm good i have no
desire nor need to beat that game i'm
good the game's fine get nothing wrong
with the game it's not super well made
but the game's fine i just don't feel
like it i wasn't feeling it wasn't
vibing wasn't getting it all in my soul
you know what i mean and that happens
that happens with games sometimes i just
don't vibe with it and that's okay
because i got sleep to do it is late uh
this last video is going to record today
anyway and frankly
i want to go to bed so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out these horror games
they're all listed down in the
description below there are so many more
scary games for you to check out in the
description and in the suggested videos
right down there they're delicious
they're nutritious and they're good for
you just like dr pepper so thank you
everybody so much for watching ring the
bell if you want to know when new videos
are coming out and as always i will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you